[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster and I'm Constance and
kissin and this is a show for you if you
want honest conversations with
fascinating people and our guests do not
get more fascinating than the man we
have back for the third time today is an
author and journalist Douglas Murray
welcome back to trigonometry where it's
very good to be with you both again
although eventually virtually yes indeed
well that is something that is obviously
affecting everybody what do you make
first of all before we dive into lots of
other stuff that we want to talk about
about how you know our societies are
coping and handling the the crisis and
the situation well I mean gosh there's a
lot there I mean depends individually
people you know people's situations are
varying enormous ly some people have
almost seemed to regarding it as being a
sort of reset sort of some kind of
vacation some people are being paid and
being paid their salary without the
inconvenience of having to go into the
office and enjoying some of the perks of
that but I think for most of us I mean
it's just an incredibly concerning time
whether we're through the worst of the
virus or not I don't know but I know
that in some ways it just all feels to
me like the preface to something as if
this is a prelude because every day you
just see news about the economic
consequences of this just wash past that
would have been enough news for months
only little while ago so I'm very
concerned about it like everyone isn't
and trying to see my way through this
but but yeah I mean this is it's like
having to get used to an entirely new
program isn't it and do you think we're
focusing because you brought up the
economic consequences and well I
continue to exist in a sort of woke
liberal bubble well though currently
getting expelled it prodigiously
religious right but do you think we're
talking enough about the economic
consequences of this douglas or do you
think we're simply glossing over it
underneath all the hysteria
the problem is the first stage of this
has been dictated rightly or wrongly by
the experts in pandemics of I religious
and so on and and that's of course
crucial but there are other factors that
are now clearly unavoidably coming into
play and you know we have this not easy
question in our societies at the moment
which if we had good faith societies
good faith discussions we could have a
bit more openly in the general public
but but I think broadly speaking it
comes down to it's already clear that it
comes down to what level of risk were
willing to take versus the economic hit
that we're willing to put up with him my
worry is that that for a lot of people
this this moment we're in is like the
moment of you know the cartoon character
runs off the cliff the legs are still
spinning and he remains in air for the
time being but you know no society can
keep going running up debt like this the
government can't be effectively
employing half of the workforce of
paying for half of the workforce so
that's what I worry about and and I I
don't know it's an incredibly fine
judgment call on behalf of governments
and others I'm just I'm just deeply
alarmed by you know I think it was a
poll last week or the week before from
you guys saying that 28% of the British
public don't want lockdown to end even
if the five conditions that the
government has stipulated are meres
and you know you think well how are we
going to get back as a society how we
how are we going to reacquaint ourselves
with with the concept of the risk which
we're almost certainly gonna have to
reacquaint ourselves with some people
just like to be confined and dominated
by the government I think the 28%
perhaps but do you sense that just sorry
to interrupt there but in some people
also like doing Farkle but anyway so
yeah
that isn't a small consideration of
course as I say I mean if if your salary
is basically being paid for you you
don't have to go into the office anymore
and you've got you know a nice house of
the garden sort of thing these these
these could be seen by some people as
being halcyon days as I say we're we're
off the cliff you know in economic terms
but coming back to that very point
Douglas one of the things that I was
wondering about is do you think that
this Kurt this Korona crisis has kind of
exposed how human beings just we're not
wired to think of trade-offs we just
think oh I'm enjoying this now therefore
I won't necessarily look into the future
or you know these people are dying now
but I'll not even be able to think about
the people who are going to die as a
result of the measures we're taking now
to keep these people safe like we just
don't seem to be able to process this
idea that there are no good decisions
anymore no that's that's certainly true
there are no no there are no good
decisions in this particular episode I
mean one of the things that struck me
first when this so I know I've not spent
any part of my life thinking about
pandemics before now is so you know I
I'm wary of the people who present
themselves as experts who also hadn't
thought about pandemics until now but
you know one of the things that struck
me early on was you know I was thinking
about that extraordinary moment in that
I've been reading a lot of Tolstoy in
recent weeks and I was thinking of one
of the few work spheres I'd read before
all this death or even ilyich where
there's an extraordinary moment where he
he thinks is he's dying he thinks it
reminds him of that time that he was on
a train and thought his destination was
that thought the train was going in one
direction and then realizes it wasn't it
was always going in the other direction
and I sort of felt something like that
when this all began it was the uncanny
feeling of how on earth could something
like this happen followed by no this is
the sort of thing that happens this is
this is history this is this is how
history feels things you've totally
discounted because they happened in the
past happen in your time and you
have to reacquaint yourself with the
concept though this is this is this is
the direction in which we go and you
talk you talk a lot in the board that
your previous two books I've read about
you know it seems that the West is in
crisis almost when it comes to identity
politics and also when you discuss it in
the West in the death of Europe and it
seems to me that people in the West
because I spent a lot of my time growing
up in Venezuela don't really understand
what it's like when a society is in
crisis and when a society is very very
near to the point of collapse and I've
get quite anxious because you're looking
around and you're thinking this can't
carry on forever but it's teams that we
buried our heads in the sand do you
think that's the case well there's
something I wrote about etching the
strange death of Europe celebrated early
20th century Spanish philosopher wrote a
famous book called the tragic sense of
life and I I speculated there that that
it was Western particularly Western
European you could also say of course
North American men and women who
basically in the last three quarters
were essentially lost the tragic sense
of life lost lost a particular
understanding of how life can go and we
undoubtedly slipped into this you know
somebody must be to blame somebody else
must be able to get me out of this
this isn't fair all these sorts of
presumptions you know to which as we
know from history and most people in the
world still know the response the
universe is well was so what what makes
you think you're special and I think we
had had lost that I by the way I I don't
take any comfort as some people seem to
that this virus whatever comes after it
in some way miraculously vindicates all
of their thinking prior to the virus
despite never having thought about the
virus before I'm a little notebook of
the number of people who have never
written about this sort of thing who
find miraculously that the coronavirus
vindicates everything they said about
everything
before you know I mean like people say
to me you know I imagine that the
identity politics people will will learn
from this they'll go away if you want a
bet in everything plays everything you
know everyone is using the virus as a
sort of megaphone for whatever their own
pre-existing ideas but that's always the
case well we will really wanted to get
into that it'll be later but do you not
think maybe as a counterpoint of what
Francis said is actually you know we had
a guest on the show Jim Rickards the the
US finance and economics exponent he
said you know one of the things that
we're not talking about is the veneer of
civilization is paper-thin and it's it's
already crumbling but actually I mean I
look around I think people are pulling
together people of you know the level of
compliance with water extremely
significant restrictions on our freedom
is very very high you know you don't see
people on the streets protesting about
it you know we're following the rules
even as we find out you know the date on
which they were based may or may not
have been accurate like I kind of I
don't feel the society is crumbling
around us you know what I mean I I don't
especially either I think one point I
made very early in this was that it was
striking to me that given that in a
society like Britain we'd been said to
have been living in a divided society in
recent years there was you know
unbelievably rent and broken and we
trusted nobody in authority I was just
very struck by the fact that that it
turned out we had massive amounts of
societal trust we had trust in our
politicians who we may have had
criticisms off but we broadly recognized
we're trying to do the best they could
in the circumstances we were in we
trusted the scientific advice experts in
the UK you know the Queen's messages
have have been of enormous importance
you know this just strikes me because
yes we've been said to have been one
thing and then a crisis comes along and
it shows it for being a certain amount
of hot air i I do however think that we
have had little flickers of reminders of
what societal chaos does look like I
mean I think that
the the the glimpse into chaos we saw at
the very beginning when people started
stockpiling was one very I think that's
something that people won't won't forget
once they've seen it and I think a
second example by the way is that
fascinating I mean I say it the sort of
talking about as a historian but I mean
I they're just fascinating historical
thing of people starting to burn five G
masts you know that I mean that is the
sort of thing which just when you read
about pandemics and disasters in history
you know that the outbursts of
irrationality the vulnerability to
irrational ideas the conspiracies and to
much more again that's that's the sort
of thing you read about in history books
but to see it happening here and now to
the extent that you know there's a
really perhaps necessary attempt to shut
down the people spinning the stuff the
causes people to go off and do that
it's fascinating I'm it's a outbreaks of
the irrational mind and I think those
are sort of useful for us because they
provide a corrective to our presumption
of our age which is that sort of Whig
interpretation of history presumption
which is that things just keep getting
better and better some point soon we can
all properly put our feet up five gmasks
of the new Jews is what you're saying
they'll almost certainly be connected in
the conspiratorial mind I hope you
enjoying our brilliant conversation with
Douglas Murray we wanted to take a
moment to say a huge thank you to all of
you who've been supporting the show
during this lockdown one of the things
we tried to do during the lockdown is to
produce a lot more content so instead of
just the one interview a week what we're
doing now is we're putting an interview
on Wednesday and on Sunday and also
we're streaming live every day except
for Monday's as well so we're really
taking it up a notch and you guys have
responded absolutely and thank you once
again for tuning in for listening for
commenting for retweeting but there is
something as well that you could do if
you wouldn't mind now we know that we
live in financially straights and times
and things are tight but
if you can afford to contribute to
trigonometry maybe slip a little cheeky
fiver in to the paypal or the patron or
whatever else it would really help me to
eat we don't want your fiver and Francis
doesn't need to eat look at his fat face
what we want is a monthly subscription
if you can do it because that helps us
to plan ahead and keep the show running
lots of you have responded on already
and we really appreciate it
and with that enjoy the rest of our chat
with Douglas Murray but when you bring
up the free speech issue and obviously
we have seen some censorship by
government and big tech companies of
people who have been putting out these
conspiracy theories and I was curious
what you make of that because well as
you know I'm very strongly opposed to
restrictions on what people can and
can't say I equally I don't think in a
situation where people are going out and
burning things down allowing that to be
fueled by people is a good thing so I'm
genuinely uncertain where I stand where
do you stand on that well it is it is
that very important issue isn't it on
the incitement question which we've all
been sort of badly playing around with
in recent years primarily because
certain people for short-term political
advantage dishonestly claimed that
anything they don't like is incitement
but incitement as a concept in law it
does exist and it's a very important
concept it basically is you know the
limit is you know you can say all sorts
of things about people but you can't
stand outside their house with a mob
pointing to the house and say you know
attack so it's about the the the
proximity of the threat as well as the
words I think this is really really
tricky but for the tech companies they
are getting it wrong but they're getting
they get everything wrong because
they're they're trying to learn on their
feet and play with tools much more
powerful than they expected them to be
and do it in super quick time I mean I
think that some of the stuff I've seen
that has been read about has been
censored it is obviously material that
should be out there and able to be
thought about
but I can't deny that I mean when it
comes to people spreading conspiracies
that you could see easily or swiftly
catching on among some people in the
time of already considerable confusion
it's a tricky one I mean my general
belief is is to leave everything up
there leave everything out there but it
must have crossed your minds as it has
mine of you know it's worrying when you
see something like the David Icke
controversy that the normal almost
beginning of this whole thing with the
program London real which I don't know
III was interviewed on that when my last
book came out and the interviewer was
right nice and did quite a good
interview and got um well but you know
some point in the interview he mentioned
yeah that's now this India David Icke
was saying the other week and I was
interviewing him and I just thought well
why were you interviewing him and and
then of corporate there is the follow-on
from that which is the thing as I say
that must be on our minds are in this
which is well when they interview him he
gets millions of hits and and what I
mean what is that who are the people
what is the what is the gap that is
being addressed there and these people
who just enjoying playing around with
some crazy [ __ ] are they is it something
about him that they're enormous he
attracted you I just don't know you
should ask Francis he keeps demanding
that we get David Icke on the show right
the only reason I do it Douglas is I
just want him to explain to Constance in
his face why he's a lizard yes I would
pay to see that I tried to explain that
to a friend recently who's not from the
UK and and no knowledge of David Icke I
would say yeah no no no he was like well
you know even the football and then I
said Jesus in a style suit on live TV
and it is it's extremely hard to explain
it's extremely hard to explain and then
if
you know all the royal family lizards
and that's his argument yeah and so no
it's a tricky one but but I do think as
I said that's that's one of the
questions underneath although which is
what is it that he's speaking to
what's everyone else missing or are we
missing something I don't know it's it
but but yeah I'm worried about I'm
worried about the fact that the tech
companies are at the very least going to
be hoovering up and canceling things
that should be considered because some
people are doing that sort of thing and
it's it's definitely I think it's
probably you know it's it's it's too
close all of that stuff with internet
censorship has always come too close to
comfort for some of us you know it just
is you something all they're only gonna
get David Icke you may you discover that
they you know they demonetized
you know all your friends and they've
they've started putting watch things on
people and yeah it's it always comes
closer to your boat than you hope well
there's another thing that they have
been doing as well which troubles me
tremendously which is they are playing
around with algorithms on YouTube so
then what they call authoritative
content is seen by more people than
unnethe or attea content so if the two
of us were to interview a coronavirus
expert that would not get the same
traction as CNN interviewing that same
person so that they they've got the hand
on the on the levers of information yes
yeah which is what I think is
explosively yeah they have they say they
have far too much power they're playing
around with others that that's bigger
than they can cope with they're having
to relearn incredibly fast things they
ought to have known a long time ago
about the nature of free discussion and
free debate but iiii by the way there's
a one reason why i said you know it's
worth trying to think about why there's
an appetite for some of the craziest
stuff is that i mean i'm i'm
increasingly wondering although you just
alluded to it earlier constantine i mean
i'm increasingly wondering what happens
if it is clear
shown and seemed to be the case that the
scientists overestimated or indeed got
very wrong some of the things that have
caused us all to be in lockdown now for
a couple of months I mean so the point I
made at the beginning look at the
societal trust we have isn't a rather
wonderful thing you think actually I can
easily foresee the circumstances where
this completely backfires I let alone if
we had to do this again or what asked to
do this again I mean if the scientists
who we've been relying on hoping uh
correct and trusting art do turn out to
have got this badly wrong then the
conspiratorial mind will have had an
awful boost won't it
no absolutely and moving on now since
somewhat have we touched on it earlier
on in the interview but you didn't seem
surprised at all that people were trying
to put their own spin on the virus
racialize a virus you know the fact that
the virus is now fat-shaming people it's
also a racist you that didn't surprise
you in any shape or form why not ugly
well no because we all we all come to
the world with the understanding that
we've you know put on it one of the
fascinating things is that you know
religious people put a religious bent on
things people who believe in sort of you
know sjw ism that's the sort of religion
to them it's the lens through which they
understand the world if you've
approached everything up till now in the
presumption that you live in a racist
patriarchal system normative society and
that all of these things need to be
pulled down in order to get to some kind
of justice then the coronavirus is
simply the latest thing you can use to
prove that you're right and then you do
this weird stuff they've all been doing
of you know the virus is an teen women
and then people point out the more men
die and they say well the men might be
doing the dying but it's women who are
suffering from it or something and then
you have this awful outburst of debate
about
whether ethnic minorities are
disproportionately suffering from the
virus and indeed dying from the virus
and instead of being able to even begin
to have the discussion of if that is the
case why might it be you have the this
is yet more evidence of the fact we live
in a racist society a society so racist
we can't even import a virus from China
without making it into a more racist
virus and and and on and on it goes and
of course is you know as I say be the
amazing thing in a way living through
this is is seeing something I they say
that that so few people have thought
about and so many people just keep
instead of thinking this is a this is a
new thing for me to consider this is a
new thing for our society to be thinking
about instead of thinking about that
thinking how can I adapt this reality to
fit my pre-existing lenses and you know
I feel rather sorry for the people who
are doing that because among other
things it massively limits a ability to
comprehend the world around them it
limits their imagination it limits and
the real problem though isn't it is it
it limits our societal capability to
solve problems that's what I mind about
it like I minded this after the London
riots in 2011 I minded the fact that the
Commission set up to look into it and
why they happened set up and decided in
advance what the answers couldn't be
because it just means that what's the
point why not just not have an inquiry
why not just pretend it didn't happen or
or just say whatever you want and and
and that's the problem with this is I'm
just struck by the fact that we have
some really complex issues ahead of us
most obviously this this competing thing
between being safe as much as we can
from the virus and the economic
imperative but in that really difficult
space in a discussion we need to be able
to have we so just disastrously
it ourselves I saw dawn Butler was on
the television I think this morning as
we're speaking claiming that Boris
Johnson's announcement last Sunday about
how people should get back to work if
they can was deliberately sending people
out to get the virus and you know you
think oh god how can we be so stupid as
a society to allow a discussion at that
level as if the debate is between the
Pro and anti death parties although you
know Pro infecting the elderly against
the Pro defending the elderly groups by
how are we gonna solve any problems when
we've got stupidity at that level hey
guys and welcome to Rancho erotica
aka my bedroom but we've got a brand new
sponsor this week and it is Babel their
language learning app and bad boy is
brilliant if you want to learn a
language maybe you haven't had a chance
to learn another language because you're
thinking of going to another country and
tough you can't but this is the next
best thing
Babel will have you learning a language
in next to no time so you'll be talking
like me and then in a couple of months
you'll be all I want 2/3 of it got my
theft that I said a reset what if I wore
no I mean Gary and Birbal who's a
brilliant app to use because it's got a
clear simple and easy to use interface
and it's designed to get you up and
running and speak in your new language
within a matter of weeks with 10 to 15
minute lessons every day so it doesn't
matter your competence whether you are
an absolute expert or you're English
they'll get you up and running in next
to no time and here's a great thing
about babble is that it teaches you
real-life conversations there's none of
this oh la bibliothèque or la piscine
nonsense right because we all know that
you can't go to the swimming pool during
Corona so the lessons have been lovingly
created by over a hundred language
experts those are real people it's not
by a translation machine and you can
learn up to 14 different languages
that's French Spanish German Italian I
mean those are the only languages I know
but I'm sure there's others so they
though
the teaching method has proven to be
effective across multiple studies and
it's available as an app online and your
progress will be synced across all
devices as well right now Babil is
offering our fans six months free with a
six month subscription with the promo
code trigger all you need to do is go to
babble dot co dot UK forward slash pike
and use the code trigger on your six
month subscription and for the people at
the back babble is spelt b a b b e l dot
co dot uk' slash play promo code trigger
the world has gone upside down I mean
Piers Morgan is retweeting a shocker
something is badly wrong here but I you
know I see your last time we spoke we
spoke about your latest book which is to
your left behind you and a new product
placement yes the madness of crowds
where you talk about a lot of this stuff
you know race gender the trans
conversation as well are you not
optimistic Douglas because we have seen
a few small steps in the right direction
I would say I mean for example the the
review of the gender recognition act
recently came out and said that you know
children shouldn't be allowed to
transition until they become adults
although I do take your point about we
seem to have taken a very strange look
at ethnic minority suffering from the
virus when if you speak to your doctor
they they go okay well obviously those
groups would be most affected because
they're more likely to have diabetes be
overweight etcetera etcetera right but
are you know optimistic do you not feel
like we may start to see some people
become less extreme about things as a
result this of course you know the the
TV people the pundits they're gonna
continue because that's the livelihood
right yeah you know the TV feminists or
TV race baiters or whatever but broadly
as a society do you not feel that we are
maybe starting to move in the right
direction you know let me just preface
this by saying that of course I mean I
just
I'm deeply conscious all the time of
need to avoid the tendency to have these
things vindicate your own point Lisa I
have a natural predisposition to hoping
there anything something anything does
away with the woke [ __ ] at some point
I've got a natural pre-decisional
just don't want to talk about in a
moment longer than I have to I don't
want my I don't want my brain cells to
be clogged up with this detritus and and
so of course I wish it was the case I
just see that you know the same games
being played
I suppose my my my short my more my my
prediction such as it is or he's stupid
to make predictions at any time taking
out my prediction in a way of that at
the moment is this I think that I think
the people who do that they're going to
double down but the rest of society is
going to have less tolerance for it I
and I think that's because Lionel
Shriver said this recent as well that
you know the woke stuff was always a
rich time and a rich people's obsession
I mean it was a it happened because of a
society that didn't have enough problems
you know it we didn't have enough of the
things that were being complained about
you know it's only if you've got a
society that doesn't tolerate aggression
that you can decide to go to the layer
below that and decide to police
microaggressions like no Society in
history before ours would have given a
damn about so-called microaggressions so
it's it's a product of wealth boredom
bad education illiteracy and much more
but but it's it's I'm pretty confident
that as a mossad Lee that as we're all
upper we already are suffering
economically many many people have lost
their jobs don't see how they're going
to be able to keep their finances
together I just expect that those people
are going to care or even
less than they already did if Sam Smith
claims somebody misgendered him
according to what he claims to be this
fortnight and and I think that's fine I
think that'd be a healthy thing I think
I think we have as I say we've all had
our minds clogged up by a lot too much
nonsense and but as I say I mean you
know both of these things can happen
simultaneously
people doubling down and the wider
population saying no we've we've had
enough of that we've we've got real
problems now so we don't have time for
your imaginary ones and Douglas we've
spoken a lot about the negatives of this
virus in its impact and of course they
are there are a lot of them are there
gonna be any positives do you think is
there anything that's gonna come out of
this might actually help society move
forward I'm skeptical of the concept of
forward I don't like this view of
history I think we may have discussed
before I think this whole idea that we
just always going forward even a virus
can be used to get to a better place and
happier people and I I just don't I
don't see that the view of history no
it's it's famous most famous proponents
you know highlight a load of things in
the 20th century and have to ignore two
massive world wars so I'm the one I
think there are things that you could
judge to be as it were good in certain
ways to have come from this I do is a
very small seek instead I think say but
I believe in community and the
importance of family and I believe that
people's people find their most meaning
in their lives from genuinely meaningful
relationships and that's the world of
sort of virtual you know having
thousands of friends but nobody you can
rely on is something which is just how
to counter blast I mean people are
relying on their networks of loved ones
and I think that's probably for a lot of
people provided a kind of salad tree
note in their lives who are you know who
are the people who you do want to you
know have whatever the household bonding
arrangement is that we're allowed to do
at some point in the coming weeks or
months who do you actually want to be
close to and able to see I think there
have been amazing outbursts in in towns
as well as outside of towns and cities
of communities working in a way that
they were fairly unsupported and until
now and and that's of course that's the
sort of view of how a nation like
Britain works its books small platoons
you know not people being told by
government you must do this and you
should organize like this but just that
the small platoons of society self
organized self reggae and go out there
and deal with with problems that they
can solve and I think there's definitely
been a boost for that and that's no bad
thing but other than that it's quite
hard to put a positive spin on a
pandemic I think one of the positives
which I want to talk to talk about in a
second as China and potentially
reviewing our relationship with that
country but before we get on to that
Douglas you obviously someone who not
only writes books but articles as well
and I wanted to ask you what you make of
the the journalistic response and how
that sector of our media is coming out
of all of this because a lot of people
including myself have criticized many
journalists for the reports as not the
journalists but the reporters in the
press conferences for what I felt were
you know endless pointless got your
questions and things like that do you
think journalists overall have done
themselves proud and this in this
episode no I don't think so but I mean
no that's because so few were prepared
for it I mean I say myself but I'm as
being guilty of this and a member of the
tribe but you know most people in the
media and journalism did
you know no nothing humanities courses
at university they are very ill-prepared
for discussions about biology or science
or hard maths or anything like that and
so I think that the reason why
journalism's had a bad virus is because
we were programmed to do a certain type
of game which was totally insufficient
for the era we find ourselves it and and
the games are ones like gotcha games
which is why I think the public opinion
trusts the Pitney Bowes will show the
trust in journalism gone solo because
people didn't really feel that was
adequate to the task and then you've got
the you know the I've said it before but
you know the u-turn game the one of you
know well you said this last Sunday but
now you're saying this isn't this a
u-turn by the government as I pointed
out the other week and a piece somewhere
I know there's any driving those u-turns
a morally neutral thing um it's quite a
useful maneuver times if you're going
straight into a wall you you turn ought
to be deployed and you wouldn't want
somebody to say you just done a u-turn
hmm
it's not it's not you know as I say if
the advice changes of course you might
will change or change your view but it's
that sort of thing
Italy like the game of trying to expose
differences between people at the top of
government that's sort of that sort of
thing well of course it's at this this
guided the journalistic community in
recent years it wasn't fit for purpose
then it's definitely not fit for purpose
now so no I don't think it's I don't
think it I don't think the journalists
have had a great war at all what about
the police Douglas because this is
another part of our institutions I
suppose that that seemed to have
struggled with particularly initially
with how to deal with this we saw a lot
of police forces around the country
doing seemingly very stupid things
yeah and taking liberties if you like no
they certainly have I mean they well
this isn't terribly surprising by the
way I mean there are quite a lot of
examples we could point to across recent
decades that showed that the police
among other things there's always a
problem and they operate in a way like a
gang I mean I'm saying internally they
always try to protect their own they
always try to cover up for each other
often with catastrophic consequences and
and and they can't concede when they get
things wrong they don't anything
meaningful about it so the police
overreacted and undoubtedly in certain
cases went beyond what the government
would allow them to do in terms of
policing and I mean this you know these
preposterous things like the police
point of dying a lake to prevent people
swimming in it and and sending drones
out to photograph dog walkers in the
complete wilderness and and much more
but but in a way that's sort of what I'm
afraid that's what I expect the police
which is you know not been operating
very well as a force for a long time
it's not terrible but it just has
definitely has terrible moments and in a
way that's I'd expect the police to be
vaguely incompetent and for some of them
to massively overreach because they
can't believe their luck they can go and
you know tell off a sunbather because
after all it's much easier telling off a
sunbather than it is actually going to
somebody's house and they've been robbed
and actually investigating the robbery
and finding the robber you know I mean
when you think of what the police have
not bothered to investigate in recent
years yeah crime that goes on which is
on CCTV which is why the CCTVs meant to
be there and the police don't even
bother to investigate it I mean this
happened you know everyone has stories
of this and as of course they just can't
believe their luck when they can walk
around and tell people you're killing
people by lying there on the
I'm less surprised by that than I am by
the public reaction which again and now
this is a minority admittedly but I
think we get quite an interesting
insight into again what history is like
look at the people and where we all have
stories open sometimes we read about
them in the press look at the people
willing to inform on their neighbors you
know I've spoken to a lot of people
others you know people who you know
people they know who say to them you
know are you aware this is the second
time you've been out today
no and when you hear stories like that
you know I I didn't write think gosh you
know it's that's how things like East
Germany the Soviet Union that's that's
that's partly how it worked isn't it
because there's always a portion of the
population that loves the opportunity to
play this sort of combination of comets
are and and and policemen and purity
police and you know cleric and kirtan
twitcher and all of that there is a
proportion of us maybe we've all got a
bit of it in us who loves said look at
the shaming that goes on on social media
when anyone can get a photo by the way
quite often the photos from years ago
what months ago over of people men to be
in a public place and everyone online
can say how can these people and they
can all pile on they feel so great about
themselves that they wouldn't do this
and you know that instead that stuff is
is really interesting to see come out so
I'm a much more surprised at that in a
way than I am at the police over at
overreaching and Douglas you talked
about the police and do you think that
the government because in times of
crisis governments always introduce new
taxes they always introduce new laws do
you think with the introduction of this
app that what we're going to see is an
infringement of our civil liberties
we're gonna now be tracked far more than
ever and then we're just gonna have to
accept it I actually don't think so
particularly I'm I think there's itself
there's an overreaction to the
overreaction which is to claim that
therefore we are slipping into being a
police state I don't know
people who say that apartment me also
the people who always claim that we're
slipping into a police state and III
died I'd be very surprised if after all
of this sabri's public are eager to have
this sort of thing going on more in
their lives all of the time but there
will be a proportion of of people who
will like that 28% we're talking about
who would like to remain at home
whatever happens you know for the end of
time there will be a portion of people
who will who will you know claim well
look how well we took that maybe you
know it doesn't matter if we have more
detection and following and and all that
sort of thing I just I think that'll be
pushed back against I think that I don't
think they'll get an easy ride with that
I don't know I don't think we're gonna
slip into some talat area nightmare well
see I was quite reassured by how
reluctantly Boris Johnson introduced
some of the restrictions of Italy they
seemed a very strong reluctance from him
to do that and what's against all of his
political instincts is that you could
see it in his eyes something he never
ever dreamt you'd have to do mmm
but equally I am also somewhat persuaded
by the argument that you know after 9/11
a lot of laws come in in America none of
them have been rolled back you know the
counterterrorism legislation in this
country introduced in the wake of 77
then it's used to to remove a pensioner
who's Hecate I'm glad the Labor Party
conference right yeah there is there is
a sense that I mean most of these lots
of grandfathered I think so I guess they
should they should be removed
automatically but I I there is a thing
there that sometimes things don't get
rolled back the way that you'd hope even
if yes there is voice said there has to
be incredibly I'm thinking with the
example you give the counterterrorism
legislation I always thought that the
arms are - it is quite straightforward
you come down like a ton of bricks on
anyone who misuses and miss applies the
law so that you know the first counselor
who you know allows anti-terrorism
legislation to be used to spy on
somebody who's putting out the wrong
color bin
dad person should have never been there
public life again nobody who cooperated
with it ever should be you know I just
have you a better understanding and a
better punishment of people who misuse
legislation intended for very serious
and specific purposes and misuse it for
their own weird short-term political
convenience hmm or to pursue a vendetta
or whatever so yes I mean I I just think
that needs very close I kept on it but
I'm pretty confident we we have a lot of
close eyes on that sort of thing in the
UK hello and welcome to my bedroom aka
Palacio Orgazmo now we've got returning
sponsor this week it is hellofresh
they're the UK's leading recipe box
company delivering fresh pre-portioned
ingredients straight to your door no
fuss no hassle during what is a
difficult time for everyone particularly
the most vulnerable people in society
I'm looking at you single men hello
fresh have been working round the clock
to be delivering fresh food to as many
people across the country as they
possibly can with twenty delicious and
easy-to-follow recipes each week that
means that you can break away from your
tried and tested classics the carbonara
we know you all do it lads
and that way you'll be able to create
delicious easy-to-follow dinners that
will ensure that your girlfriend doesn't
dump you whether it's a quick and simple
recipe or after or maybe something to
help get you laid
hello fresh have something to cater that
every taste and if you fancy making a
meal of it you can also add lovely extra
little details to your box like handmade
bread do desserts and lovely bottles of
wine in case you're feeling cheeky
everything that you need to cook and
enjoy delicious homemade dinners
delivered straight to your door dinner
is solved with hellofresh
and who knows maybe even your love life
and we've been talking about a slide
into totalitarianism which is a lovely
way to introduce China how much how much
responsibility do you think the Chinese
or rather the CCP should take for this
particular virus well it all comes to
their door and what whichever whichever
explanation we end up settling on as to
how this virus came about whether it's
the wet market one or the or the
laboratory one and whether it seemed to
be entirely accidental partly accidental
or or entirely deliberate every single
one of these options the Chinese
Communist Party has to pay for it
because in every single one of these
scenarios they the central thing remains
not just that they that this happened in
their country possibly mother
laboratory's but that they managed to
they successfully deceived the world for
months and did what to tout her in
regimes always nice to do which is to
turn a local disaster into an absolute
global one and I'm I think that we have
a very complex but necessary process
ahead of us of disentangling ourselves
from this country which we've this
regime I say which is which has just
burned down the world economy and do you
think do you think you should pay
reparations oh I'm absolutely everything
I think everything should be on the
table absolutely everything I look at
look by the way at the disgraceful way
that the CCP has treated our allies and
friends it's it's it's bullying of the
Australian government I mean that
Douglas because many people won't know
about this so the Australian I've
written about this a bit recently
because I've taken a certain interest in
this corner of things I think that I've
written this in the past I think this
country has been very naive the UK has
been very naive about the Chinese
Communist Party I think we've seen it
solely as a sort of gold
tap and ignored the downsides that
always come with it and by the way I
told this story in spectator last week
in my column but I I heard this story
very very good source seven years ago
that after the Dalai Lama affair which
was when David Cameron the then Prime
Minister saw the Dalai Lama who of
course the Chinese Communist Party a
loathe for obvious reasons to do with
Tibet after David Cameron met the Dalai
Lama the Chinese Communist Party cut off
trade relations with new investment
deals with the UK until David Cameron
announced that he was going to socially
distanced himself from the Dalai Lama
and then announced he actually never
meet him again and after issuing an
incredibly groveling apology the next
time that British representatives met
with their Chinese counterparts in
Beijing a copy of the British
government's apology was pushed across
the desk at the British officials who
asked to stand up and read it out and
they did and when they sat down the
Chinese Communist Party officials said
with a smile we just wanted to know that
you meant it now Wow when I heard that
then I was bowled over anyone being so
supine on my behalf or on their behalf
of the British people but that's the
deal there's a deal we've been willing
to put up with which is you get the
money you get the investment that isn't
nothing but it means that you also have
to play on their terms and they're their
caveats involved and some of them are
very serious now in recent days and
weeks your Australian government has
come across this because the Australian
government the Australia is just stress
I mean has been learning what we are
just learning now faster and ahead of
time because of their location and their
own trade relations in recent decades
with China and I've just noticed on
visits Australia that that the public
there are much more aware than they are
in the UK or America about the fact that
there are things attached to this
relationship and the Australian
government
a couple of weeks ago asked suggested
there should be an official inquiry
independent international into how this
all happened how the virus originated
and and how it came to spread across the
world and after the Australian
government did that the Chinese
Communist Party reacted in the way it
always does in threatened Australia it
its diplomats its ambassador to
Australia said that the Chinese might
stop buying Australian products
Australian beef Australian wine and that
this was seen as a racist thing
incidentally I mean one of the most
prominent government's mouthpiece
journalists in China took to way more
the Chinese equivalent of Twitter and if
you if you if you think that Twitter is
a tower terian censorious monolith you
should see their Chinese counterpart
there but this very prominent Chinese
boat basically government stooge took
two Chinese equipment of of Twitter to
say that Australia was a piece of
chewing gum stuck to the shoe of China
and it needs to scrape them off and
that's quite normal rhetoric from the
Chinese Communist Party's officials
represented that sound a little bit
racist Douglas isn't it interesting
isn't it interesting that whilst you
know whilst you know people like whilst
Nancy Pelosi and Co are worrying about
whether or not saying where the virus
came from his racist and you know let's
not forget it was only in late February
early March the Nancy Pelosi was still
encouraging people in America to go to
their local Chinatown in order to show
solidarity and the mayor of Florence at
the same time was urging the people of
his City to find a Chinese person and
hug them in order to defeat racism and
coronavirus simultaneously which turns
out to have been the sort of reason
perhaps why Florence was in lockdown
faster than anyone else but what the
whilst we were all obsessing with with
this you know is it racist to say that
it comes from from China the Chinese are
perfectly willing to be as racist as
they like about everyone else in the
world as if we needed room
deserve that after what they've been
doing to the weaker people and others in
recent years so this is a classic
example of where the real world meets
our stupidities you know the real world
of China ACO doesn't give a damn about
racism doesn't give a damn about it but
knows that we do and is willing to say
anything alikes about us and manipulate
our fears and so anyway but to get back
to this point yeah the Australians are
now in this situation where the China
China is stopping boycotting certain
Australian products they basically try
to teach the Australian government a
lesson
for daring to stand up to them and
daring to suggest an independent
international inquiry into the origins
of this virus well you know I think now
is a time for solidarity I'm pleased to
see that New Zealand government has very
much backed up our Australian friends
and allies but I just think I think
that's that this is a fine moment for
some democratic solidarity and to say
you don't get to you don't get to if
you're a Chinese Communist Party bully
our allies and expect us to distance
ourselves from them you know and and I
yeah I think everything's on the table
with China after this nothing nothing
III nothing I'm not open to and Douglas
do you think this is the end of
globalization as we knew it I I don't
see well that's a really tricky one for
us globalization means several different
things partly it partly it's a
demonstrates in some people's mouths
it's a description of just the world we
live in in other people's mouths it's a
a particular concept of how we should
live and how international trade and
travel is organized one version that I
visit the version used for the mean it a
night is what I mean the idea that we're
in this interconnected world and that's
a universal positive and you know that
the fact that you can buy goods from you
know Beijing or wherever it is and that
has no impact
whatsoever oh yeah no I think that the
this this virus will have one
particularly clear effect which is that
we will be much more conscious in each
of our countries of supply chains and
the need to I mean if we'd have had a
conversation in January and we'd have
been sitting here and I just said or you
just said look you know I don't I think
we've got to have British medicines in
order never to have to rely on Chinese
medicine you know or anything like that
I think we would have all felt it was a
little bit that means you know there
would be something on the edge of it
which wonder sounded quite right
especially in my accent you know what's
the problem with I mean you know is that
if it's cheaper and we get it and is my
point is that even now just a few months
later it's a perfectly reasonable very
sensible thing to argue that that that
we shouldn't be reliant on China China
in crucial product and I think a lot of
countries not least the Mediterranean
countries that saw the northern European
countries and going incredibly
protectionist with certain items early
on in this virus will obviously be
addressing themselves to that in the
coming years on the wider thing of a
globalization yes III who knows we
globalization is an extraordinary thing
which we all rely on and we get so much
good from it's it's given us all an
incredible boost in our standards of
living the ability to enjoy products we
wouldn't be able to enjoy as well as
much more but there is always a downside
and the downside of this is is I think
clearer to us now so I don't think it's
an end to globalization I think this
this will be seen to have been a kind of
corrective to the most glassy-eyed pan
Gaussian vision of globalisation
and and there is and I wonder that I
would have thought that there will be an
increase in the attraction of that
critique of globalization which was
already going on particularly from
America Takeshi from the Trump
administration which is basically that
that the benefit does not accrue in the
same proportion as the negative that is
that the benefit you and I accrue buying
a beer by being able to buy certain
products cheaply does not actually
counterbalance for instance the loss of
manufacturing jobs in our own countries
now that argument was already going on
it was quite advanced so a lot of people
including American president who
obviously in favor of that at least
sympathetic to that critique I just I
think that will that was already growing
and I think it will continue to grow it
definitely was it definitely was but I
think it goes in terms of you know you
make the point about supply chains I
think it goes slightly beyond concern
about medicine and wherever us it might
be because people are you know in
economics they talk about externalities
and this is what you're really talking
about is people are now becoming aware
that when you buy a widget for $1 from
China you do that because there's nine
dollars of hidden cost and the back end
of it some of which is manifested in a
global pandemic that causes a global
depression and that that is the price of
doing business with China in the way
that we've been doing and if people
understand that I think our relationship
with China is going to be very different
to the way that it's been up to this
point yeah III agree I I it's it's I
would not feel enormous ly rosy about
the future if I was a Chinese Communist
Party she's bad news for them but the
good news for us well we found a
positive note after although it is it is
remarkable when you think that isn't it
I mean we this this hangover from the
last century
they're still going on look we've talked
about very little in our lifetimes we
just you know I I want I often wonder I
mean that game you can play of you know
swapping communists for fascist or
fascist for communists or seeing how
tolerant you are of the other
totalitarian if there was a massive
fascist state still in existence run by
a fascist party with more than a billion
people under its complete and
totalitarian control I wonder if we
would have been quite as gleeful about
getting cheap t-shirts have you know
heard Donald Trump and Boris Johnson are
both fascists I know everyone everyone
is alright yeah yeah no of course I'd
heard that I get your point of course I
do so someone who comes from the Soviet
Union not only to me it's a very weird
it's abhorrent it's apparent that you
can have someone go on national TV in
this country and go I'm literally a
communist and that person is treated as
as just another person commenting you
know yeah if someone went on TV and said
I'm literally a fascist I think they
might be treated slightly differently
yeah I know it's true I mean her
counterpart Nick Griffin actually denies
being a fascist but you know if he was
to come out full fascists I'm literally
a fascist you're trying to pretend I'm
just some other kind of crazy guy yeah
it wouldn't have been career making for
him in the way that it was well we have
found some positive Douglass before we
let you go as usual we have a question
for you but actually before Francis ask
you that question
give us a scoop are you working on
another book at the moment I am I'm in
the earliest stages I've quite lucky as
an author and I have a backlog of books
in my head I know I need to write and
it's a question of what order to do them
in so the the state that we've all been
thrown into in recent weeks and months
is both very uncomfortable for me and
also something which is
useful because I've had an awful lot of
reading and things to do and and I am
sketching out at the moment two books
which I've been wanting to oh people are
gonna be excited give us a little bit I
have a I have a total rule on this that
I never talk about books that I'm
writing or have because what happens is
you become like one of these people in a
Paris cafe who talks about their books
and never writes them talking about
books is that is the death of actually
ever getting around to write them and I
did in the past once talk out a book
there was one book I should have written
which I never got around to because I
talked about it so much
so I know where I've I speak on this and
my incredible rudeness and refusing to
even play with your question justified
well the sad fact is Douglas is the
cafes aren't open so the metaphor
doesn't work but also you can understand
Douglas I'm Russian it's my job to push
expect to push boundaries but we've got
one more question for you and the
question we always ask which is what is
the one thing that people aren't talking
about but we really should be oh god
it's kind of unfair on you because
you've been on the show a couple of
times now and the more you come when
trigonometry the more difficult that
question is to answer before you run out
of I think yeah I'm the thing that I
really serve we started it may sound
like I'm dodging it but I do think we're
not talking enough about how the hell we
pay for this
I just am filled with filled with worry
about this I've been saying for a long
time I think one of the reasons why
people have been playing with crazy
ideas that not worthy of them is because
very basic things had already gone wrong
in the economy you know I said this
after 2008 crash that you know that when
the finances go bad other things happen
we know this from history and yet we
didn't think it would happen in our own
time well the finances weren't bad in
2008 and we
still hadn't got our way out of that and
now we're in this I I the one I'm really
worried for I have to save people I'm
now 40 but people 20 years younger than
me and 15 years younger than me who are
you know starting out I just I I really
do think they've got a very legitimate
set of concerns that need to be
addressed I just don't know how it was
hard enough for my generation to you
know do things like getting on the
housing that and the last something was
never easy but I just don't know how
this generation is going to accumulate
capital and if you can't accumulate
capital it's not clear why you should
have any instinct of love for capitalism
and from that a whole set of problems
can flow so that's that's that's that's
really what preoccupies me at the moment
it the thing I wish we would think about
is this is an almighty going wrong of
the economy and what will happen as a
consequence of it what might we be
vulnerable to you know we already
discussed at the beginning you know
there's this small but considerable that
you know small percentage with a
considerable number of people who are
vulnerable to Icke ISM didn't see that
coming in the recent past
so what else what else can we be
vulnerable to when things go this wrong
is becoming popular among young people I
know and you know that the tragedy of
that is you know is is just because one
thing isn't working as well as it
doesn't mean you should try again the
worst thing in history yeah absolutely
well that is a good note on which to
leave the interview Douglas we ask you
on behalf of all our viewers not to do
any more interviews so you can focus
solely on writing the two books even
coming because I think everybody's going
to be very excited about seeing those
come out and thank you as always I
encourage people to follow you on
twitter is Douglas came Arie that's
right yes yes somebody else taken
Douglas Murray I don't know who that is
should be banned from history entirely
but you've got the two brilliant books
your most recent books behind you the
madness of crowds and the strange stuff
of Europe and we obvious
I recommend for anyone who hasn't read
them yet to go and read them it's a
grand pleasure thank you very much
Douglas and thank you for tuning in and
we'll see you soon bye bye
[Music]
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word